und auch der streit um angeblich zu
wenig vorhandenen impfstoff für die
booster kampagne eskaliert in einem bild
vorliegenden brief der cdu wehrt sich
die union jetzt gegen entsprechende
vorwürfe der spd ist würden insgesamt 60
millionen impfdosen fehlen ja dort heißt
es ganz genau ich zitiere einen blick
auf die fakten zeigt dass das ein
durchsichtiges politisches manöver ist
um die spd von der großen koalition
abzusetzen und mit einer kampagne gegen
uns zu starten das verunsichert die
bürgerinnen und bürger in einer ohnehin
schon politisch angespannten lage
zusätzlich und ohne not karl lauterbach
ruft feuer um dann feuerwehr zu spielen
obwohl er weiß dass es gar nicht
bei uns im studio ist die person die
diesen brief verfasst hat der
gesundheitspolitische sprecher der cdu
csu kino sorge und das seit zwei tagen
hallo herr sorger guten morgen herr
sorge sie nennen karl lauterbach den
neuen gesundheitsminister
mit anderen worten einen geistigen
brandstifter das ist ein sehr massiver
vorwurf geistiger brandstifter haben sie
gesagt aber wir waren das ist das was
sie letztendlich sagen in ihrer
formulierung er sagt da ist feuer damit
er anschließend feuerwehr spiel wir
waren alle sehr verwundert dass karl
lauterbach quasi nach einer inventur wie
er sie genannt hat festgestellt hat dass
angeblich zwei impfstoffe da sein soll
die zahlen geben das nicht her wir haben
geschaut was ist an den zeilen dran wir
haben es mehrfach nachgefragt auch beim
bundesgesundheitsminister haben da keine
antwort bekommen er wird sich wohl heute
in der bundespressekonferenz dazu äußern
was ich persönlich schon für einen sehr
schlechten stil halte wir haben deshalb
auch gesagt wir wollen dass er die
zahlen offen liegt es wird dazu eine
sondersitzung des ausschusses für
gesundheit diesen freitag
höchstwahrscheinlich geben und das was
ich gemacht habe das was wir als
fraktion gemacht haben war letztendlich
nur die zahlen die ja herr lauterbach
auch zugrunde gelegt hat einmal zu
vergleichen dass heißt wie viele
impfstoff dosen sind da wie viel im
stock zu diesen werten noch geliefert
und da zeigt sich dass millionen dosen
selbst wenn jetzt alle 34 millionen
menschen die zur musterung in den
nächsten monaten anstehen würden sich
sofort boostern lassen wollten wer
genügend impfstoff da und deshalb weil
die aussagen sehr sehr durchsichtig also
sie garantieren und heute bei uns auch
in der sendung dass es anfang des jahres
februar märz keine engpässe geben wird
ich sage nur wir haben allein dieses
jahr bis zum 31 12 über 40 millionen
impfdosen zur verfügung also genügend
impfstoff damit jeder der zur musterung
ansteht das machen möchte was wir alle
wollen gift und gemustert werden kann
für das nächste jahr gibt es verträge
das sind verträge die geschlossen wurden
sind allein im ersten quartal steht
dadurch nach den verträgen genügend
impfstoff zur verfügung und letztendlich
ist es ja sehr überraschend dass gerade
derjenige karl lauterbach die immer mit
am tisch saß aber auch olaf scholz der
seit anfang des jahres die taskforce
impfstoffproduktion mit seinem
langjährigen vertrauten herrn gruppe ins
leben gerufen und geleitet hat also
immer mit am tisch saß das jetzt so
getan wird als als wisse man nicht die
zahlen und was ein impfstoff verfügbar
ist warum sollte herr lauterbach der
immer ein gutes verhältnis mit herrn
spahn hat da jetzt in irgendeiner weise
übel nachtreten und wie soll ich
verstehen dass der haushaltsausschuss
gestern zwei milliarden euro für eine
nachträgliche bestellung von impfdosen
bewilligt hat wenn sie sagen es ist doch
genug impfstoff da er im grunde muss man
ja sehen dass wir auch bei der frage wie
verändert sich das virus
modifikationen gesehen haben also die
omikron variante war ja auch im letzten
jahr in der form nicht so vorhersehbar
deshalb ist es ja auch wichtig dass man
immer wieder auf neue situationen
reagieren kann sprich gegebenenfalls
auch zusätzliche impfstoffe beschaffen
kann und das ist ja mit den verträgen
durchaus vorgesehen und da ist es jetzt
auch aufgabe der neuen bundesregierung
perspektivisch das nächste jahr im stoff
zu besorgen aber jetzt sondern hatten
die möglichkeit deutschland hatte die
möglichkeit zusammen mit der eu als die
cdu csu nur noch in der regierung war
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen eine
option zu ziehen bei biontech für eine
bestellung von millionen von
zusätzlichen dosen diese option haben
sie verstreichen lassen es ist ja
momentan so nach den verträgen das für
das nächste jahr option in höhe von 80
millionen dosen zur verfügung stehen die
auf 160 millionen erhöht werden können
und letztendlich müssen wir auch schauen
wie sich das virus entwickelt die option
war aber im spätsommer und im frühherbst
das wäre dann für januar da gewesen
diese option haben sie verstreichen ist
ja letztendlich ist ja das was herr
lauterbach momentan macht eine
momentaufnahme als wir reden ja gar
nicht über die dosen die verfügbar sind
also letztendlich ist das ja die annahme
dass im nächsten quartal überhaupt keine
einzige dose zur verfügung stehen würde
und das ist ein sehr unrealistischer
fall und jetzt müssen wir schauen wie
diese dosen die wir einerseits noch
haben und die die geliefert werden
tatsächlich für diejenigen die sich
pusterla sind bei uns zu verfügung
gestellt egal wie es am ende ausgeht ist
es ja alles ausgetragen auf dem rücken
der bürgerinnen und bürger die natürlich
durch solche aussagen wie von herrn
lauterbach oder auch durch ihn jetzt
durch diesen brief ängste haben sorgen
haben dass das alles nicht hinhaut dass
man die booster impfung nicht bekommen
kann ist es nicht vielleicht an der zeit
dass man einfach sagt man dass diesen
kleinkrieg untereinander einfach mal
sein und man zieht an einem strang
ja ich hätte mir das auch gewünscht
zumeist eine amtsübergabe zwischen jens
spahn als vorherigen
bundesgesundheitsminister und herrn
lauterbach gegeben hat da hätte ich mir
durchaus gewünscht dass man selbst wenn
es diese probleme geben würde was ja
überhaupt noch nicht belegt ist herr
lauterbach hat bisher keine zahlen dafür
vorgelegt er hat überhaupt nicht
begründet wie er zu der auffassung kommt
dass man zumindest nach einer lösung
gesucht hätte aber jetzt so zu tun als
sei in den letzten jahren im letzten
jahr als man auch zusätzlich mit am
tisch saß nichts passiert und man kenne
die zahlen es nicht ist ungefähr so wie
wenn man in einer guten beziehung ist
und für alles gemeinsam zuständig ist
und danach sagt ich habe von nichts eine
ahnung gehabt und das ist glaube ich ein
durchschaubares politisches die inventur
hätte ersparen natürlich auch machen
können und die exakten zahlen übergeben
können wir sind gespannt heute
nachmittag 15 uhr wird karl lauterbach
erstmals zusammen mit rwe chef wieder
eine pressekonferenz abgeben und da
werden wir dann näheres erfahren vielen
dank für den besuch im studio danke